will you cut my hair why it's been six
months since Matt died and that's like
three inches of grief hair and I don't
want it on my head anymore
why are we trying to be okay
on the outside there is a nuclear
holocaust you occasionally use a section
as a barrier to self-exploration to
having sex people would judge you for
cheers I can only see the hole not left
not the people standing around it you
are so selfish you make everything about
yourself but it's my first Christmas
without Matt and my first Christmas
sober how hard that must be for you
maybe I should just go maybe you should
when will you be back
I'm not sure I'm coming back
[Music]
no Danny Matt would hate it if you knew
you're never going to speak to me ever
again I don't want to hear you talk
about what Matt would have or what never
Warner well we both know he wouldn't
want any of this the person who made us
in-laws is dead I don't know what's
going on I do he's in love with you and
he feels appropriately terrible it's
normal to lose some of that connection
as you move forward is there a way you
can make to our mind dream about someone
but if you want to see him you're gonna
have to find him on his plane comet
comes out tomorrow
we made his dream come true I want to
see him I just want to touch him
and this is my life and I'm going to do
things that make me feel good
if it's so hard to just say I'm sorry
I'm sorry
[Music]
so story
[Music]